nick foles is going to waltz right into
free agency the philadelphia eagles and
look here's what happened we had harry
roseman on the program yesterday we
played some of it earlier in the show
they tried to trade him
they tried to set up the tag and trade
they knew it wasn't going to work so now
they're they're doing the right thing
and making it known to the world they're
not going to tag him if they thought
they could have traded him they would
have tagged him and traded right also
they don't want to lock the money to the
franchise tag or anything like that
right because they are one of the teams
that are in kind of uh dire straits
right the salary cap if you know you're
not going to be able to trade i mean
apply the franchise tag he signs it and
you got to back up that money's just
sitting there exactly right okay so what
we're going to do because falls is now
in the pool right and there are other
these are the best quarterbacks for 2019
who are available free only 2019 too not
like the future right right right so and
we're gonna we're not flipping a coin
we're gonna do rock scissors paper are
you ready rock scissors rock paper
scissors are you gonna be able to
scissors paper rock i choose it's rock
everybody here it's rock paper scissors
shoot listen rockhead let's just do it
okay one get your other hand there all
right rock paper scissors shoot
i got the first choice uh i i got to go
for one year i got to go nick foles
we've seen what nick foles can do we've
seen how he can capture
magic lightning in a bottle and we've
also seen what happens when he was with
the rams i'm willing to take that chance
though because i think we've seen enough
of what you need to do to coach nick
falls the offense you need you can't jam
him into a tough spot and look it was
the rams it was all due respect i love
jeff fisher but jared goff they were all
offensively challenged rams with jeff
fisher case keenum was a quarterback of
the rams with jeff fisher i'll i'll call
that
the fluke and i'll say that eagles 2013
eagles 2017 eagles 2018 i'll find a way
to get that out of nick foles give me if
it's one year nick falls no brainer yeah
i get that uh that's probably would have
been my first pick as well i can't
believe you went with scissors there
damn it i'm really disappointed um but
either way he is he's a proven commodity
and he's been in a lot of big time
situations and playoff football in the
super bowl i mean come on he out dueled
a tom brady late in the fourth quarter
in super bowl 52. so that i mean that's
a a pretty good pelt on the horse as
they would say i just realized why you
went with paper because we were talking
about rocks and i thought you were going
to do it no i can't talk about yourself
go ahead
go ahead i know where you're going with
that okay my next keeper i'm going with
tyler murray that's going to be the my
pick i don't care i don't give a give a
damn that he's a rookie quarterback
i almost said crap
in other ways too but kyler murray kyler
murray uh yes for me is the number one
quarterback in the draft and that is not
going to change there is he's electric
uh he is you know i know only a one-year
starter at oklahoma and that's certainly
going to be used against me or against
him even coming out in the draft process
but i think he's a natural thrower of
the football he's a phenomenal like a
generational type athlete at the
quarterback position i did i mean really
checks every box as far as mechanics in
the pocket you know vision down the
field proper decisions going through
reads so it's a new day and age i'm not
as scared for these rookie quarterbacks
anymore they've gotten so many reps with
the the camps and seven on seven and
high school football they're throwing it
45 times a game all of that that's why
i'm gonna go kyler murray and you know
i'm a big believer in drafting a guy and
throwing him right in i thought that
brown should have done it last year
baker mayfield i am a firm believer
and look i obviously if it was more than
one year kyla murray is the guy right
for one year and one you're only eileen
foles you agreed but i i'd have gone
with you murray would have been my
second choice all right my next one uh
this is difficult it's difficult um
yeah i'm a case kingdom guy sure and i
think if you put case keenum in the
right situation you understand what he
can do well understand what he doesn't
do well you can get a lot out of a case
keenum and i still remember
we'd break down the highlights of of him
getting out of the pocket he'd reset
look down the field he instinctively
knew when the pressure was coming this
is the year in minnesota run again find
a guy wide open he really helped fuel
that team to go 13-3 is no small feat
and he had a lot to do with that last
year in denver he had his moments you
know i think the the coaching staff and
the different and they you know they
they have their system and they try to
jam the guy into the system i'm a firm
believer in taking what the guy is and
putting the best system around him and i
think i could make some hay with case
keenum with the right system to suit his
strengths yeah certainly i i don't i'm
not against you there i'm not sure if i
would have gone case keenum totally with
this pick but yes everything you said
does make sense i mean he's not gonna be
a franchise superstar quarterback but
again another guy who we've seen in some
big situations two years ago with your
minnesota vikings uh he's battle tested
he's seen different offensive systems
and schemes um so i understand that uh
it's not a horrible pick by you okay so
what's your next pick smart guy i know
my next pick um
i'm not sure if i want to go with one of
these rookies or another proven
commodity but you know what i'm going to
go with talent i'm just going to go with
the talent i'm going with drew locke
okay the quarterback from missouri and i
know that might sound crazy out there
but i this drew lockhead is impressive
to me when i watch him on film he really
is he can really throw the ball all he
has a special arm is what i'm gonna say
i mean it's a patrick mahomes baker
mayfield-ish type of arm i'm not gonna
say patrick mahomes cause that's on
another level that's another
stratosphere that's like aaron rodgers
john elway but still a special arm do
you want to say amazing what we're
saying about mahomes i know man it's all
accurate it is but after a year ago we
wouldn't have been saying no well i mean
he gave us the visual evidence of the
things we thought he could be now we've
seen it and we go oh yes okay but drew
lock
big quarterbacks had a lot of experience
playing in the sec i hear people talking
about oh gosh you know they didn't win a
lot of big games this year well he was
missouri in the sec they're not the
greatest coach football team i've seen
they were the lesser talented team on
the football uh field more times than
not so that's why i'm gonna go with him
because i do think he's got enough reps
he's very good in the pocket another guy
that hey if there's one knock on this
lock eye and i know you and i are gonna
talk about him a lot he can take he can
make a dumb interception or a dumb
decision maybe once a game uh but i
think those are things that can be
coached out of a player and when you're
on a team like missouri where you're the
lesser team on the field more times than
not and you don't have the
defense that's going to stop and make it
a low scoring game when your offense
isn't working you're forced to maybe
force the issue with throwing the ball
making some risky decisions at time but
i really like drew luck yeah and we're
going to hear a lot more about him as we
get closer and closer to the draft and
have his work out at the combine and
people start to maybe wake up to him
because it's all been murray and haskins
to a certain extent
right and you know the broncos a team
that yeah
i thought maybe that that's the
direction think about going and maybe
they still can maybe it's joe flacco for
a year or two and then
lock is one of those
out of those three or you know out of
the big three that i'm going to call
with murray haskins and lock lock is the
only one that's played more than one
year you know that's the other thing
that's going to be a knock on haskins
and murray as well you know they've only
got one year in college football and i
understand that argument uh i certainly
do reps matter you know just being back
underneath or underneath the center
behind the center and getting you know
feel for defenses and managing
situations that is important uh and
that's where locke has a little bit of
advantage over the other two guys i got
one that's going to blow your mind that
you haven't even oh
baby you've really whiffed because this
should have been your second round pick
yeah are you ready are you sitting down
i'm sitting down i know ryan fitzpatrick
for one year one year and one year only
give me right you i've had better no
oh yeah one year old okay look at what
he did last year
when he got benched a little little
that was when jameis winston was back i
mean and dirk cutter didn't know what to
do with his quarterbacks at that point
for one year of the guys available yes i
got fitzpatrick okay and i almost made
him the second round pick but i i i
played the odds there that you wouldn't
pick him well i yeah i i wouldn't have
picked ryan fitzpatrick so don't worry
you're right i can't even think of ryan
fitzpatrick no i didn't even write him
down my short list here so uh yes yes i
i can understand you know your thought
process with ryan fitzpatrick he's
certainly going to be able to understand
any offense and he gives you some
veteran leadership and he's been in a
lot of different situations but the one
thing i'll say about ryan firing
fitzpatrick you know for being the
veteran guy and everything you want him
to be he's about as careless with the
football as anybody we've seen too and i
think that sometimes gets like you know
swiped under the rug because he went to
harvard and he's smart so we're just not
going to talk about the dumb
interceptions he throws all the time so
that's one thing i would push back there
okay
oh it's really down to
ed haskins or a tie rod taylor to me
here this is it's it's one of those two
and we've forgotten about tyrod he was
on my short list and i thought
i i want fitzpatrick over tyrod taylor
but he was the week one starter the
cleveland browns he was the guy and he
got injured and now we've just forgotten
about i know and he can manage certain
situations like i look at him as a
jacksonville type of guy but at the end
of the day again i'm going to go with
i'm going to go with dwayne haskins from
ohio state i just can't pull the trigger
on time
i'm going all rookies well i thought i
was going to win the rox paper scissors
and get nick foles to start but yeah i
am rock scissors paper
shut up but either way i am going with
the dwayne haskins dwayne haskins a big
strong quarterback i mean he's almost
like a big ben roethlisberger back there
a little raw certainly gonna have some
things mechanically that he needs to
correct uh but you're talking about
another guy with some major pop in his
arm and played in some big moments and i
know it's only been one year of college
football but from what i saw from the
start of the year last year to the end
of the year it really gave me belief
that you know this kid's only going to
get better he's just scratching the
surface of what he could possibly be you
know early season hey yeah he was
getting used to playing quarterback for
ohio state and and getting used to
playing college football but by the end
of the season when they're playing
northwestern in the big ten championship
game or washington and the rose ball
mike man he made a lot of big time
throws and and some tight windows and
not a very creative past friendly
offense and that's why that's why i go
there uh
do you think both guys go top 10 haskins
and murray
i i i really i will say this i think all
three are gonna go top 15. i really do i
wouldn't be shocked if all three went
top ten when all said and done how many
first round quarterbacks which are over
under right now
did you know somebody's going to creep
in 30 yeah it is is it going to be the
big thing will be will somebody at 32 go
with the you know the the kid from duke
uh daniel jones uh jones is that am i
blanking on his name uh either way the
kid from duke he's in that conversation
you know does an auburn style get in
that conversation just a wheel will
grier i am going to say it's four
uh
but i don't feel comfortable that i can
guarantee it'll be the three i'm just
not sure it's going to take something
like you're saying somebody trading up
late into the first round or maybe a new
england takes the kid from duke and
makes that guy you know maybe the heir
apparent to a tom brady that's the thing
there isn't an overabundance of teams
looking for starting quarterbacks right
now but there are plenty of teams that
have older guys that need to be thinking
about the replacement and that's where
it potentially could be you know i'd say
three and a half is the over under for
quarterbacks in round one at this point
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports